okay let's see by getting everything
going here this has been a long day hope
that your folks is day was more
enjoyable ah up and running beautiful
ravenclaw in sweden nice to see you how
are things I mean like I'm I'm grousing
but like things things are okay I'm just
I'm tired and just a lot of stuff sort
of piling on me at the same time you
know how that goes um Oh another
ravenclaw a fair number of them in the
in my subscriber base which very cool as
far as I'm concerned
sup from Long Island I don't know what
that was like I like tried to do a Long
Island accent which actually I can't do
but then I like realize that halfway
through saying it it came out weird I'm
sorry uh happy birthday thank you it was
pretty good my my birthday weekend was
lovely I spent pretty much all of it
with my partner Liz she treated me very
well I had some great friends died like
not as many people made it out to like a
Friday outing as had planned because the
weather wouldn't cooperate but I still
got to see a lot of people because I had
a show on Saturday so it's all lots of
folks there caught up with some people I
haven't seen in a while it's uh yeah it
was a good weekend ooh Slytherin from
Australia Michigan Brooklyn man lotsa
that we got to Australians poo
slithering from New Orleans boy
Minnesota hufflepuff hufflepuff from
Chicago I like I have to wonder how many
new Harry Potter people I've picked up
now because like the
the video I ended up doing on the latest
things
JK Rowling said that that went bigger
and sparked a lot more of a conversation
than I would have thought so that was uh
though surprising in a good way
New Hampshire aa doctor who guide
welcome my friend so um I did get since
it you know this basically the last week
of the month that my birthday falls in
some stuff is still trickling in you
know just little things like the mug see
if I can there we go
the mug speaks truth so I got that the
earrings I'm actually wearing right now
friend of mine made these so that was
nice in the mail which means from you
folks got myself another flask so I now
have two Harry Potter themed flask I've
got I solemnly swear that I am up to no
good and now Polyjuice potion so that is
uh that's fun and also got twice a lot
of time which actually means that as far
as modern who knew who goes the only
things I'm missing our series ten and
eleven once I have those I should be
caught up which is nice because I was
actually fairly I was missing most of
Capaldi until awesome wonderful lovely
people um give to me them for my
birthday so that was uh I was really
nice I because I had because I had a day
at work that went very long I don't have
as much planned for this one as I as I
might normally like to have
I'm trying to oh okay so here's a
question how many people got word of the
the thing that got revealed when Marvel
dropped a bunch of Avengers endgame
trade not travel posters so this only
happened today so I don't know if I'm
about to break a lot of hearts with this
how many people already know what
happened
trying to see if I get response in on
that Oh question marks heard about it
from a friend but I don't really
understand the whole thing about well
okay um I'm not sure that it's really a
spoiler for the movie yeah there it is
so um apparently sure he went in the
snap which was not depicted in infinity
war and I know I and Liz who is abs I
haven't told Liz yet or found out if she
knows I'm assuming she doesn't know
because I will be consoling her right
now if she news so I haven't told her
yet
um but yeah sure he's dead which was a
bit of a frustrating thing to learn
because like like I said her going in
the snap wasn't depicted in infinity war
so this is kind of an awkward way to
realize oh so she's gone too because
every they basically put out two sets of
character posters a bunch of ones in
black and white depicting all the
characters gone and then a bunch of ones
in color of the ones who are still left
and sure he was among the Fallen so I'm
I'm not necessarily gonna like do a
major knock on how dare they because I
have a feeling given how close the
production of infinity war was to the
production of production and the release
of black panther they probably didn't
know just how much people were going to
love Sheree so I'm not necessarily going
to knock the the decision for her to go
and like I think if they knew how big a
hit Black Panther was I don't think they
would have got rid of T'Challa either
from being honest but it does feel
frustratingly dismissive that it didn't
even get depicted and we find out
through marketing a few weeks ahead of
the release of the film I don't know why
I don't look forward to telling Liz cuz
she she can't she loves Sheree so much
she can't even say sure he's named
without kind of squeeing
a little bit so that's not gonna be fun
to tell did you like there's two new
Dark Phoenix trailers seriously no I
haven't seen him so I couldn't tell you
a Hufflepuff from Scotland they better
bring about well of course they're gonna
bring her back okay like look don't
don't call me spoilers on this but like
people do realize that everyone that
went in the snap is going to come back
right people do realize that right like
the only the only characters who have a
question mark around them as to whether
or not we ever see them again
our characters who died in something
other than the snap so that's Loki who
is honestly probably perma dead although
he's still getting his own Disney Plus
series set it on a really a point in his
life
so like we'll see him again just
chronologically he might be gone and
Gamora gomorrah's the the other big
question mark because the way in which
she died was not the snap now depending
on how her death ties to the soul gem
maybe if the soul gem is destroyed we
still get her back but like that's a
that's debatable that's a question
really anyone who dissolved
all coming back so like will get Cherie
again but yeah still I just want to know
just want to know the how portion of how
they went and how they come back well I
mean well we'll see what we get are you
ever gonna talk oh man I get this one a
bit Oh like like let me say now because
we've got what about 80 people on it's
because people come on and off like I
want to start a thing where like anyone
who happens to be home and you're not
like at work or school or certainly not
if you're gonna drive later but like
seriously if you've got alcohol at hand
I think everybody needs to take a drink
anytime I either get asked for my
pronouns or what kind of music I like
because I feel like both of those having
multiple times every single stream um
that said coming back to this question
okay are you ever gonna talk about
Torchwood and the Sarah Jane Adventures
am I ever going to probably am I going
to anytime soon no because the thing is
I would have to revisit both of them so
like I never gotten and I haven't seen
all of either of them in the first place
I've only seen in its entirety the first
two series of Sarah Jane Adventures I
didn't see the third whoa I saw bits and
pieces I didn't see most of the third
one I haven't seen any of Torchwood
Miracle Day and even taking that on
board not a huge fan of either one of
them for different reasons my my
feelings of Sarah Jane is just that it's
pitched to such a younger audience like
it it's not even designed to appeal to
me so I don't even consider that a fault
but I'm not a huge fan of it whereas
Torchwood is just so uneven like
honestly Torchwood is so uneven that I
do honestly think it puts series 11 to
shame in terms of hmm being all over the
freaking place so like Torchwood the the
idea of talking about Torchwood in any
depth is exhausting to me I'll probably
do it eventually but like the amount of
time I'd have to sink into it to do it
any kind of justice which would require
a full reward
Wow logistically I don't have time right
now but I have the energy for it either
to Adam under 21 because that would be a
great way to get hammered have you ever
heard of overly sarcastic productions I
feel like I've heard that name before
but I don't know why so maybe good
Prosecco time thank you
Cheers uh trust me you don't want to see
Miracle Day yeah that's the impression I
got but again if I'm gonna talk about
Torchwood in any depth I kind of need to
ya know see children of earth is
children of birth is the best thing that
Torchwood ever did but even that I don't
think is flawless I think the third
episode is very padded and honestly
probably didn't even need to be there so
even the best thing that they did I
still find fault in but but why by far
children of Earth was the best thing
that Torchwood did any ideas for any
more Harry Potter centric stuff like
talk top tens are sorting other
fictional characters top tens probably
not I think largely because I know how
devoted the fan base of Harry Potter is
into like really getting down to the to
the details some thing is even though
I've read all the books I've seen the
movies more than I've read the books so
like I really worry that if I ever if I
ever tried to do top tens and like
referred to things like scenes or
characters or whatever I'm gonna end up
saying something that's in the movies is
not in the books and get called out for
it and like I don't wanna
as far as characters from other
franchises being sorted into Hogwarts
houses yes I do want to do that again
and I want to do more of that with Liz
but like trying to get our schedules
coordinated when on a time when we both
have the energy to sit down and do it is
tricky
there are some that I'm probably gonna
do on my own like I would like to
continue to do the Marvel ones with Liz
I'd like to do that with Buffy with Liz
maybe Star Wars with her but like
there's um there's other stuff like I
did a list I'm trying to think of what
some of the others were there's other
franchises where I could do it on my own
she either feels like she doesn't have
the background knowledge of the of the
franchiser she just doesn't have the
interest level but ya know that sort of
thing I do plan to do more of I love all
your videos your and your live streams
you are amazing oh thank you be Queen
Victoria Victoria for Torchwood ha ha ha
that's true that's true we get to thank
the Queen for that ah they're making the
Phoenix a cosmic entity oh ok I mean
that's probably a stupid idea
we're talking about the Dark Phoenix
movie now that's probably a stupid idea
only because to make that not feel like
it was pulled out of their ass they
really need more than one movie to set
that up and like I understand that the
Phoenix force in what well was
eventually here because here's the first
thing the Phoenix force being a cosmic
entity and something that basically
inhabits Jean Grey people seem to forget
that's a retcon and in the Dark Phoenix
saga itself that never comes up so
that's the first reason it's a bad idea
to put it in there because it actually
doesn't impact thus the primary story of
of the the main thrust of the Dark
Phoenix saga because it's a retcon so
that's the first thing the second thing
is that the the Fox x-men movies were up
until apocalypse which wasn't good and
didn't do it well we're pretty dang
grounded so like the idea of getting
into that end of the cosmic stuff you
can't just jump into it because even
though it has a precedent in the comics
in the comics when they introduced that
or even at the time they did the Dark
Phoenix stuff you know the Dark Phoenix
saga has a battle that happens on
the moon cuz that's just the stuff that
went on in comics at the time that's not
just the kind of stuff that goes on in
the X in the Fox x-men movies so
throwing it in for what is probably
gonna be the last film I guess
- audience users who don't know the
source material they're gonna go where
the heck did they get that from and for
anyone who doesn't know the source
material well it's gonna suck anyway so
you know did you ever play Dragon Age no
I never did get to that one um I'd like
there was if you ask me about any
videogame more recent than the
PlayStation 1 era odds are I have not
played it and if you ask me anything
about the current gaming generation I
guarantee you I even played it the
meantime we're gonna try and watch all
the MCU movies before endgame well
that's a project enjoy that so what what
pronouns would you rather people use
them referring to you Cheers
so hope everyone took a drink like I I'm
not I'm not baking whatever makes sense
in your own head and actually I say that
but I'm like you've been in that you
were in the chat earlier so you just you
just did it - sneaky bugger then again
how bad is it that the director of that
how about is it that the director of the
last name was the director of Dark
Phoenix not true no no because the
director of last stand was Brett Ratner
Simon Kinberg is directing Dark Phoenix
the problem is that Simon Kinberg is a
producer not a director he's never
directed a feature film before so like
you can't blame him and you can't mark
him as the director for last hand but
that doesn't mean he's gonna be good so
it's one of those things where like I'm
not gonna praise the guy but like let's
be concerned about the true things and
not and not
you know misattribute his failings
I'm not pinky is an unusual throw now uh
well played wanted to hop in and say I
appreciate all your videos in the
content and I'm especially your LGBTQ
reps thank you
I I the the last one I did is on that is
also doing quite well that that seems to
have started getting circulated again
after the fact which is always nice
because he usually you get the vast
majority of however many views the video
is gonna get within the first two days
you know forty-eight hours basically so
for something to kind of circle
background and you know keep picking up
views at a steady pace beyond that is
not typical and generally a sign that
you you probably did something right who
would win in a fight at oppose on LSD or
the petting well drunk well I mean
there's really no threat from the
adipose they're only a threat to whoever
they're jumping out of so even drunk I
think the tank takes that very handily I
don't think I'll be able to keep up with
every single streaming platform how do
you find the time for them if any
alright the the only things that I am
subscribed to for streaming are Netflix
Amazon Prime and I'm not even on that
for the streaming service I'm on that
for the prime shipping and like the
streaming service comes with it I don't
use it for much but I have it and Brit
box which is how I see classic whoo so
I'm only on three I'm not on Hulu I'm
not on CWC whatever the heck CBS's thing
is I mean
depending on how much of it is stuff
that my daughter is gonna miss once it's
off Netflix maybe I'll end up getting
the Disney Plus we'll see that one would
be on sufferance just because that is
such a massive library but do you think
Apple TV Plus was a good idea nope
Apple right now has a has an air of
desperation about them I don't I don't
think Apple has come up with something
that felt new I would say since the
maybe the Apple watch which I'm not sure
was even that good idea but it was a
fairly new idea at the time
um Apple seems to have moved away from
coming up with brand new innovations and
instead coming up with their version of
something that already exists and it has
the smell of desperation like crap we
don't have any new ideas what is there
around that we're not already making and
it's it's hard to to see that as really
innovative they're just jumping on
existing bandwagons especially when they
used to be much more at the forefront
and the leaders I mean iTunes the iPod
the iPhone the iPad you know these
things were were revolutionary at the
time that they came out I mean heck even
stuff that didn't succeed like the Apple
watch was a was a new direction it was a
new thing but like Apple TV Plus and
Apple getting into all these other
things that they announced I can't even
remember all the stuff like no that just
smells like you're going crap well we
can't think of anything new so what else
can we slap our name on but yeah and I
say that as someone who likes Apple
products my phones Apple like I've only
ever used an Apple phone and I like it
but I'm like I'm not a I'm not a I'm not
a company loyalist so if I think they're
doing something dumb I'm gonna say it
[Laughter]
do you think Dumbledore was a top or a
bottom my I think one nation is that
Dumbledore was probably a bottom and
it's it's hard to justify that but that
that's that's my gut instinct answer I
think partly cuz I don't see like here's
the thing
I think Dumbledore by his nature was
probably a switch but I will bet you he
bought him with a Grindelwald cuz
Grindelwald would not take what he
considered to be a subordinate position
and Dumbledore would in order to be with
him would would have gone exclusively
bottom boy that went into detail more
than I planned ah love your life yeah oh
my god why have I never thought about
this this is the best question that was
a lot of fun to actually deal with and
like I I do actually want to come up
with like a follow-up video to the to
the to the hairy paws to the hardwood
sex ed video cuz I had a lot of fun
making that maybe come up with something
a little more plain than structured but
in the same vein oh thank you Rachel you
and love you doing your stuff happy
birthday thank you very much
I appreciate that um Johnny Depp is so
low bottom you can't convince me well
see you're arguing the actor versus the
character so I mean tomato tomahto
top or bottom I'm sure JK will tell us
what in her next interview unless she
saw your video
there was somebody a couple days ago
tweeted out trying to remember what it
they're worried cuz it was brilliant was
like being gay is not a choice being gay
is something that is bestowed upon you
when JK Rowling feels it's time
do you know how to use the oh the sigh
not properly no I I don't I like I've
got I've got to katanas a broadsword a
claim or an axe a Cutlass and thus I up
here I don't know how to properly use
any of them I mean I like the thing I
wouldn't totally embarrass myself with
them but like I've got no training I
wouldn't know what I'm doing
have you have you checked out trans
gender dysphoria blues yet I have not
you don't need to do is I need to put
the CD in my car because my car ID does
actually have a CD player and like if I
that's probably one of the only places
I'm gonna actually think to put it on so
actually that's a good after this is
over I gotta put the I gotta put the
disc in my car and have it just be there
so on my morning commute you just be
like oh right
this do you play any video games and
what are your favorite if so I don't
really game anymore because I don't have
AI wou primarily I don't have time I
also don't have current systems like I
say you don't game I play hearthstone a
little and like I've got like ps3 and PS
2 error games that I still I still
haven't finished or in some cases
haven't played at all so when I have a
little time I go back and try and get
some time with those but not a lot like
my favourite games are primarily from
the 16-bit era so Secret of Mana Super
Metroid Mario Kart Final Fantasy 6 you
know that that was sort of my gaming
heyday well if he he was a bottom that
should have been Alba's
first clue that the relationship was bad
in my opinion a healthy gay couple don't
do the top/bottom thing I am gonna push
back on you slightly on that because
here's what I would say um any pairing
where there's a lot of emphasis put on
the top bottom dynamic means that
there is a lot of focus on sex which may
or may not come at the cost of emotional
connection and depth that I would say I
wouldn't call that boy I was gonna say
something and down now I'm just gonna
say it I wouldn't call it a red flag I
would call it forgive the terminology I
will call it a pink flag so like that
it's not like oh that's always a bad
sign but it's like that could be an
indicator of other problems um if they
if they have really prescribed like
proper roles and and actually that's not
even exclusive to two gay men I've seen
a similar dynamic with with friends of
mine in lesbian relationships you know
where some people were really fixated on
the idea of being the butch in the
relationship and that sometimes again
not always but sometimes did often mean
kind of a not great recipe as far as a
long term relationship went this is
something become lgbtq+ education our so
welcome but I imagine even you're Haller
speak in a cordial sincere manner how
are you so nice is not a compliment I'm
genuinely baffled because I do my
screaming in the car if I need to Eve I
need to scream I'll get in the car and
I'll Drive somewhere and I will shout
until my voice is hoarse and I try not
to do it at people either in person or
on video because it doesn't help there
was something I read once and it was
probably on uncracked actually but it
was nobody ever had their opinion
changed by being yelled at and then I
try and keep that in my head
also Neville Longbottom had three-way
with Luna Lovegood and Seamus Finnigan
and Dumbledore watched I mean III feel
like you're just hanging out on on
to many fan art sites some of the some
of the frisky ones oh I saw something
back here oh it's okay so I guess there
was the question about a name for use I
mean I on here I'd it's generally
Nathaniel if you want to refer to me as
Veera you can um I can't guarantee
everyone in the and the chat will catch
that cuz again I don't like I'm pretty
out on the channel but it is only one
video a month that I talk about that end
of things so I don't I don't presume
that everybody you know automatically
those were even if they get the gender
fluidity that they that they know that I
have other names I might possibly go
with the one thing I will say is I don't
I do not care for shortenings of
Nathaniel so NAT Nate Nathan like I
don't get as worked up as I used to but
not my name
so you know I was more asking because I
discuss your videos with my bf all the
time and counseled them geeks person is
a mouthful fair enough feel free to call
me Nathaniel when when discussing how
many Daleks do you know who are into
BDSM asking for a friend
well I mean they're pretty tightly bound
up in those casings like they're into
some pretty physically restrictive play
I would say thanks for your opinions on
this sometimes I let myself cry for five
to ten minutes tops when I need to
unload some steam because I am more like
that
I mean whatever whatever helps you
function you know if you need to take
time to cry there's no there's no shame
in that it displays of emotion are not
weakness if you choose to have them
privately that's fine too
so you know
the however however it is that you that
you process if it works for you that's
great
how about mr. Wayne no no no Donna mr.
Wayne is my father actually actually not
true but no mr. Wayne is Batman
so although I I did on a whim for a
little while like have my phone call me
Batman
just because I could I took the time to
cry briefly just now but animating in
the stream is keeping me happy and in
control well hey if if that if anything
I do ever helps anybody like just perk
up their mood at all that's oh god I
love that that's amazing
I blame the web comic trade paperback
Sunstone for my burgeoning interest in
BDSM okay now I'm wondering what
Sunstone is because that I haven't yeah
I don't I think I only mentioned it in
passing
um I to play what a couple of weeks ago
and it's on Amazon and I haven't I
haven't plugged it on here because it's
not all ages appropriate um but and and
you know some people would argue that
that might book on on cross-dressing
isn't all ages appropriate either but
you know that's that's people's own call
and I certainly wrote that with the
intention for it to be as accessible to
as many age ranges as possible the play
however the play I wrote is a hard-r and
it's got a lot of BDSM elements in it so
like if that's a general interest of you
if you go onto
Amazon well I mean honestly probably the
easiest thing way to find it would be
just just to look up here a while
because that's the devil was the name I
published it under its it's called when
she wakes is the name of the play and
even though it is it's a play and made
to be staged I do think it reads
decently and I also it's also pretty low
prices significantly less expensive than
the book is it's also shorter but so
like that's their that's out so if if
that whole area is your bag
give it a look maybe I don't know
shameless plug council of geeks ASMR
channel like I find ASMR interesting in
so far as how it seems like how some
people who really puts them at ease like
I I don't get it
personally it doesn't do anything for me
which like I suppose on the one hand
like you don't have to get it in order
to produce the content but at the same
time I'm like you know I I I feel like
I'd be hypocritical on it in some way or
that I wouldn't get the enjoyment out of
it cuz a big part of what I do as much
as I do is cuz I love it so how do you
listen to Doctor Who audio books I have
the the Big Finish app so I listen I
listen to my phone
pretty much what do you think of the
badges patches I send you one of them
fits the theme yes oh god yes okay um so
I the one the one that you gave me that
was for lays i did give to her um this
this past weekend the iraq the erotic
librarian match I did give to her and
and and the other one
iii-i'll I also love hang on I'll get it
because people should see this give me
one second
I'm coming right back
oh I don't know um what I'm gonna put it
on that I am figured out yet but what it
says is put fruit on pizza and destroy
the gender binary as like the banana I
don't know about that but like as a as a
fan of pineapple on pizza I I support
both of these jer stream yeah for a hot
minute there did you manage to get my
gift from England yet ah possibly um if
you're comfortable Meg like letting me
saying what it was that was sent like as
I've said at a couple points I have lost
track of who sent what if it went to the
PIO box I may not have gotten it yet
because I don't get to the peal box
daily I think the last time I went was I
think it was either Thursday or Friday
so it's possible that it's still there
if that's where it was sent to so I
right now I yeah you can you can go
ahead and say no worries but yeah they
go to the PIO box okay if it went to the
PIO box then I probably there's a fair
chance I haven't gotten to get um if I
did get it from the peel box and it
hasn't come up like cuz the the stuff I
got last time I went I showed all that
in the unboxing and QA video that could
put out actually on my birthday so
Thursday last week so if it wasn't any
of those then then I probably haven't
gotten it yet so I'm gonna try and
actually got to try and get to the peel
box tomorrow um to to get any any
stragglers that might be there did you
enjoy the the album I did I this the
question came up I haven't had a chance
to listen to it yet actually as soon as
this is done I'm gonna put the CD in
cars so that it's there and I can have
it listening going to my morning commute
oh I catch a live stream yes you do
welcome I can always trust someone who
loves pineapple on pizza that may be a
unpopular opinion but thank you live
streamed time blessed me I didn't have
to miss it because of practice oh well
good I'm happy you like the licorice I
did actually that was uh that was very
cool too why are we talking about food
now I'm hungry
Oh actually you know what I need to
anyone who follows me on Instagram
already got treated to this little bit
of wisdom but I was given these this is
supposedly a a 2-byte cupcake
yeah no two bites my button just got out
of work just i dinner a new subscriber
nice to see you
hahaha good I'm not the only one who
eats them like this yeah I'm I would pay
it's always a weird eye image to me when
somebody takes something small and like
bites it and a half they're like oh what
are you doing that just always looks
weird to me wait you have an Instagram
I do have an Instagram i i have an
instagram under very wild so if you if
you go on instagram at ver a while I
don't have an Instagram for counseling
there is an Instagram for council of
geeks but it's not me it's not like a
case of like somebody pretending to be
me um somebody just like I I don't even
know how old it is I can't remember I
stumbled across it once
but yeah very wild is on is on Instagram
I finally finished my my short story so
relieved
ah I see the quotes around short how
short did it end up being cup cupcake
sandwich hmm do you have a fictional
crush oh that you think I would I
honestly don't know Vera
oh how is wild spell its w y LD e just
think of the most pretentious possible
way you could spell that as a last name
that's how it's spelled so uh yeah I
don't know like there are there are
fictional characters who all crush on
like in the short term like for the for
the length of watching something but it
doesn't usually linger or last all that
long so I I don't have a go-to answer to
that I should figure out like I need to
like do a a deeper dive like into my own
memories that like I may have had one at
some point but there's some reason I
just kind of kind of drawing a blank do
you think it's time for society to
accept men's mental health more seeing
if suicide is the biggest killer for men
under 45 I think there's a lot that as a
society we need to and I'm gonna be
really careful hi work how I word this
that we need to do better by men ah
and I don't mean that like an immense
rights advocacy kind of way the way that
that those kinds of people tend to mean
it what I mean is because the image of
masculinity has been you know this
pillar of strength for so long there is
a lot of lack of help for men because
the presumption is a real man
doesn't need help and that comes in a
lot of forms that that certainly
absolutely affects mental health but
just in general a lot of the a lot of
the resources that are available for men
to get assistance whether it be for
mental health whether it be because they
are the victims of sexual assault or
things like that there's this
presumption that well that doesn't
happen to real men so the there isn't a
proper handling of that in a lot of ways
and a lot of a lot of areas and that's
not to imply that like oh well we handle
mental health of women just fine why
can't we do it for men no things like
that and in terms of like reporting
sexual assault or whatever we actually
are kind of bad at that across the board
but like I feel like I'm not sure that
there's as much of an awareness that we
are sort of failing men in some ways
that are different from how other
demographics are being failed by these
systems if that makes sense so somebody
somebody said they went to the Instagram
and we're surprised by what they saw I'm
very curious as to whether or not there
was a specific image that evoked that
reaction I probably should have warned
if you're going to the very wild
Instagram it's primarily um
burlesque related stuff so it's I mean
it's Instagram you can't go full nude
and I don't perform full nude anyways
but it is about as racy as you can get
away with on Instagram it's a different
vibe from this channel probably sure
giving you a heads up on that
this stream is that an educational hug
yeah this is turned into like kind of
slightly laid-back let's talk issues
live stream which I wouldn't have
expected but I'm I'm kind of enjoying
yeah
fYI my story ended up 21 pages in all
and 11,000 words that's solid nice work
do you watch anime not anything current
I mean I love animation as an art form
so I have an appreciation of anime but
I'm but I know most of the time when
people ask me do you watch the anime
they mean shows and I'm way more likely
to watch an anime film that I am a show
and even that said I'm not nearly as
steeped in it as most people be like oh
I love anime like I do love anime but
like if I say that there's an
expectation of the volume of stuff that
I would have seen that I just don't meet
so what's your favorite Pokemon I don't
have one cuz I only I really only ever
played a couple of hours worth of
pokemon yellow and it was fine but I
just didn't I just didn't stick with it
and I was I was a little too old for the
cartoon when it came out so it just it's
not it's not one of my fan of one of my
one of my fandoms oh you seen love death
robots on Netflix I'm almost done with
it and when I am finished with it yes
there is gonna be a video on that
because I do deaf I definitely have
thoughts on love death and robots
I took a burlesque class once very funny
ya know they totally are it looks
seriously if there's a burlesque lass
anywhere near you and you can work the
schedule I like recommend it for
literally everybody I mean everybody
every age every size every gender
variant including just this male I think
you'll just have a heck of a lot of fun
and burlesque is one of the most open
like all our welcome artistic
communities I've ever been involved in
so like I'd seriously I can't recommend
it enough thank you for your content and
you have the best intros on this
platform happy birthday mom thank you
very much
it's funny the intros they vary wildly
some of the bite
a fair amount of thought into and others
I just like I sit down to started
recording I realized crap I didn't think
of what to say but say is the intro bit
so some of them are very off-the-cuff
and some of them have a little more
thought behind them like the one the one
that started off the the sex edit at
Hogwarts thing that that one I I that
one was bland and I was I was pleased
with how much people seemed to get a
kick out of that what's the difference
between burlesque and drag oh boy okay
if you uh if you're alright but I I
could honestly fill the rest of the time
with this and I don't want it so I'm
gonna ask you to specify are you asking
me the difference in the art form or the
difference in the artistic community
because those are two very different
answers
so let me what you're asking and that I
will address ah don't to be mean but
trust me
there's most sexist countries and
there's not much suicide yeah I'm not
entirely sure I'm following your
statement on that I specifically mean
the art form of burlesque and drag okay
so we're talking the art of drag versus
the art of burlesque drag is drag is
much narrower than burlesque is because
drag has a handful of very specific
expectations primarily when it comes to
the physical presentation of the
performer excuse me the physical
presentation of the performers as well
as the kind of thing that they are going
to do so drag comes up a couple of forms
you have the main ones being some form
of lip sync and basically a variant of
of insult comic stuff you know a lot of
shade throwing and and sort of
quote-unquote edgy humor but the
expectation while dwell specific
some of dress style may vary like you
get goth drag queens and you get sort of
balling gala drag queens and you get you
know drag queens you know in daisy dukes
and like that can vary there's a very
specific aesthetic to the makeup that is
expected the the big hair is often a big
part of it the drag by its nature is
intended to caricature and extreme
exaggeration of femininity or more
specifically the tree at R abuse that
society prescribes as being feminine
burlesque is much broader in its intent
burlesque burlesque I actually consider
to be more of a medium than a very
specific thing what I mean by that is
the only thing that is expected in a
burlesque performance and this isn't
even always the case but generally is
that there is some degree of a
striptease involved meaning to some
extent clothes that you start out the
number with you will have fewer of them
by the time the number ends everything
else is wide open it can be funny it can
be sad it can just be incredibly sultry
it can be angry it can be political and
there is there is so there's such a wide
spectrum of what in again in my
experience and realize I haven't done a
proper drag show in about ten years so
how much the the culture of drag may
have sort of eased up and gotten less
rigid that's possible I wouldn't know
but burlesque has such a such a broad
range of what you can and what people do
within that art form that I don't I
personally don't think drag comes even
close to drag is much more about
perfecting a smaller smaller scale and
performance that whereas burlesque
I just feel is much more you couldn't
almost anything could happen
boy that that went on for a little bit
ah yes men's mental health is so
important speaking as a trans woman if
men's mental health were better than I'm
I may have been in to transition much
much sooner yeah
like that's that's honestly that's
something worth worth taking on board
that a man questioning their gender
identity like I feel like in in some
ways things are getting better for trans
women who know they are trans women but
men who are questioning and it made them
ah crap can people just lose me just
lose me my buffering or my buffering or
is it only on my end oh I think it's I
think it's sorted out can i ha ha ha can
I have the Oh God come on oh no no no no
don't do this crap
ah shoot
Oh am i good cuz on my end it's still
looking weird actually hang on let me
try something here uh did that okay yes
maybe alright cool
okay sorry so any questions that it
before the whole lag thing happened I
would have missed
Oh watch Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood um I don't want a watchful
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood because I
watched all of original Full Metal
Alchemist and while it wasn't bad I
found it to be incredibly overrated and
I started watching Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and I'm like this the things
that bugged me about the last one are
still here so no not gonna so uh sorry
started off with bottom Dumbledore now a
lovely lecture on dragon burlesque
yeah we've really kind of run the gamut
on this one drag lag
what's the dumbest thing you've ever
heard someone say or do um I honestly
don't know because most of the dumbest
things I've heard people say are
comments that I end up deleting and then
I purge them from my memory ah I'm not
an anime guy but I would like to give it
a chance any suggestions well like my
first suggestion is broadly speaking if
unless you have a strong preference for
long-form storytelling would be to check
out some movies first and get a handle
on
the art style of anime and obviously
like specific directors and an artist
will vary but there is a there is a
pretty clear anime aesthetic so I tried
to start out with some movies music he's
usually good for that though that's
usually younger age aimed summer Wars is
one that I will always recommend will
always recommend pretty highly for
anybody the girl who lived through time
ghost in the shell' though that one you
have to watch the subtitle because the
dub sucks if you wanted to go for shows
I couldn't tell you much about what is
on currently a lot of people recommend
Cowboy Bebop I'm not as high on that
show as a lot of people are somebody
just suggested Akira yeah I'm also I
also don't I also think Akira is highly
overpraised but apparently I'm a
contrarian to some degree wolf children
is very good pepper paprika was good I
don't think it's aged great but as far
as shows like I said Cowboy Bebop gets
recommended a lot and Cowboy Bebop
is very accessible well I do feel that
shows a little bit overrated it is it is
one of the more accessible ones because
it's not as steeped into in the in the
very culturally specific ends of anime
that can sometimes be distancing if
you're not used to them what bothered
you about the first Full Metal Alchemist
so it was a lot of little things that
bug me about Full Metal Alchemist the
way in which it went about telling its
story I felt it kept undercutting itself
and also it indulged in some of the
anime tropes that I just don't like like
I don't like the free shot big
exaggerated Oh sort of face you know
style usually done for comedy that
animes do sometimes in full and Full
Metal Alchemist did
that as the Brotherhood in the one
episode that I saw and I really don't
like that though when that kind of thing
happens and like okay to give you an
idea of the kind of like it's been a
long time since I've seen Full Metal
Alchemist but to give you an idea of the
kinds of things I'm talking about when I
say an undercut itself so a whole big
fundamental core conceit of the entire
world and the way that alchemy works
within this universe is that you cannot
create something from nothing there has
to be an equal transfer anything you
create has to be made from something um
and basically something has to be lost
for whatever new thing you create that
is established immediately it's like the
core tenant that says this entire thing
is built on and in episode 1 1 we see a
character who appears to break this rule
and we find out that the lead characters
entire thing is finding a way to break
this rule so I'm like you tell me that
this is a pillar of your world that you
built and then you immediately undercut
it and yes the guy in the first episode
turned out to be a charlatan but it's
like you can't subvert my expectations
on a rule what I haven't lived with it
for more than like a couple of minutes
then I just feel like you don't know how
to how to parse out this information
information in a way that makes the
narrative work and that's the kind of
stuff that would happen throughout that
show that would bug me law of equivalent
exchange yes that's the one ah crap I'm
buffering again on my end I don't know
if it's that's happening for anybody
else ok
demons of the Punjab or Father's Day Oh
demons of the Punjab easily I'm not a
big fan of Father's Day I hate the
Reapers too much okay
oh geez boy we ate up an hour really
geez boy we eat up an hour really fast
everybody I don't know how that happened
um yeah uh n-no I'm not like just
downing hard water it is one of the like
I did alcohol that one time but it is
just why have you watched Death Note and
held girl I have not seen either one of
those like I said I a lot of current
anime I just haven't seen like stuff
that I've seen all the way through four
series I've seen stand alone complex
both the first season and second gig I
have that's ghost in the shell stand
alone complex I've seen Helsing I think
I saw all of Hellsing Ultimate or maybe
I didn't get to the end of that one I
can't remember that later installments
got hard for me to get ahold of I've
seen escaflowne which to date is my
favorite um anime series and I've seen
Cowboy Bebop I think that's it for
things that I've seen the complete run
of I think so why is the rum gone uh
there's never enough of rum strange
dresses and shape-shifting
semi-consciousness Time Machine love for
adventure is miss Frizzle a time lady I
mean yeah I mean did we ever write doubt
that in my mind the only question is is
miss Frizzle a time lady that we've
already met is Miss Frizzle
Susan is Miss Frizzle Romana is Miss
Frizzle Missy I don't like
the idea that she's a timely like yeah I
feel like that's a given
blinker turn left blank turn left is
fine I just don't love it as much as a
lot of people do one punch man is great
I watched the first episode of one punch
man and it was pretty good but again it
became one of the many things that are
like this is fine but I don't
immediately like feel the driving need
to keep going and so I haven't gone back
to it try Sailor Moon but stay away from
the dub due to all the the translation
oh sorry all the trans erasure yeah I
know a little bit about that but I'm not
sure sailor moons my bag like in general
I have a feeling if I tried to our
sailor moon I would just spend most of
it going I think I'd rather be
rewatching the new Shiro so what can you
do
yeah I did sea glass I had I did a
review of it a little while ago you know
what you know what I haven't seen and
it's not out like any like within 50
miles of where I live and I'm really
ticked off us it's not playing anywhere
near me I'm legitimately ticked off
right now because I want to see that
movie so burned us shows usually take
out LGBT stuff in the dubs yeah that's
true of anime and also of videogames in
some very weird instances although also
in one random instance accidentally
inserting trans content where at least
officially it was not ever intended to
be there yeah translations are weird
things and he plans first Shazam well to
see it in review it I think Shazam is
one that I'm not that stoked about so
like if it's convene
for me to see it I will and if I see it
I'll review it it's just it's not what
I'm gonna rearrange my my schedule to
see what instance
oh okay so Berto from the Super Mario
games if you happen to have the original
Super Mario Brothers - and still have
the instruction booklet for it which I
do in the American version of that it
says that Berto is a boy who thinks he's
a girl official line from Nintendo is
that was a translation error and was not
ever the original intention of the
character and officially she is just a
girl in all subsequent Mario media but
I've got the instruction book so I do
know that from once upon a time in one
territory at least Berto was trans did
you hear Fox wanted to remake tore to
over the street Captain Jack I didn't
but thank God they they did not do that
can you quickly dab no haha no and that
that I will not do I I'm 37 years old
I'm not gonna dab there needs to be a
hard cutoff for that kind of thing
Doom Patrol is so good I would like to
see Doom Patrol but yeah I'm just trying
to just trying to figure out again it's
it's you know it's time but can you flaw
no I can't I like on a whim I tried to
figure out if I fell I can kind up but
like the instant I start thinking about
it it throws me off and I can't do it
so I think I I think I'm gonna wrap it
up
venom combined with Deadpool would
defeat us easily
uh 37 I thought you were just thirty oh
well thank you I will take that as a
compliment so thanks so much
no don't go oh
you you folks so now I I am I am gonna
wrap it up i I've got I need to well I
need to figure out if I'm gonna shoot
another video or if I'm gonna work on
editing cuz I both of those I need I
need to be working I thought you were 20
you're a liar
Gabe you thought I was 20 bowl-like heck
you did but random question before I go
because this was something I I thought
about and I then I'm like that would be
fun but I'm like what anybody care so
I've had and at least two videos now
people compared my laughs to the Joker
and I'm debating like as a lark like I
don't know I was gonna say may be able
first but it wouldn't really be April
Fool's it would it wouldn't be a joke
that would just be silly which is like
to do like various traditions of various
kinds of laughs various Joker laughs cuz
like I which Joker well that they're not
impressions is just apparently I have a
very a laugh that passes for uh for
Joker so I I mean people if depending on
how long you've been on the stream you
would have heard it earlier my sort of
bursting out laugh is kinda is kind of
very Joker's but yeah it's yeah I have a
repertoire okay so yeah I'm gonna ah I'm
gonna wrap it up there what time's the
stream next week okay yeah next week is
also gonna be nine o'clock so I know
it's gonna end up being nine o'clock
three weeks in a row when normally I try
and do nine seven nine seven but this
would have been a seven o'clock except
I've got work stuff that was keeping me
late so
[Music]
uh you know I had to do nine and then
next week is the one that was always
coming oh dang hey Tracy when the
choices the Joker always do the mark can
i've always do the Joker mark hamill
preferred well yes have you ever watched
The Sopranos I have not seen The
Sopranos
is Veera a top robotic than veer is a
switch Veera always is it always has
been a switch depends on the mood you
catch but yeah okay I will okay yeah
I'll probably for for the fun of it I
will probably end up doing a joker lap
and I can preview you folks a little bit
as I sign off for the night
so kind of think all right so I could
give you I could give you the the
sinister build I could give you the
explosive cackle or I could give you the
complete madness what are people feeling
before I head out and see laughs I'm not
sure if I could do Missy
make it rain to make him stay that works
madness madness complete madness madness
okay give me a second I just scared the
dog you're welcome